mais pour commencer on parle des taux
d'intérêt en haut ce qui mettent à mal
le secteur de la construction oui qui
dit taux d'intérêt fort dit moins
d'emprunt et donc moins de projets de
construction les chantiers se font plus
rares ce qui nuit au secteur du bâtiment
plus 35 % de faillite d'entreprise dans
le domaine de la construction en France
à louant par exemple un couple a vu le
chantier de sa maison stopper net car
leur maître d'oeuvre a mis la clé sous
la porte et ils ne sont pas les seuls
dans cette situation Florent Clavel
la fenêtre
encore une connerie ici
une maison inachevée ouverte aux quatre
vents pourtant Matthieu et Marion
devrait déjà y habiter depuis cet été
sauf qu'après le début des travaux il y
a un an et de premier quoi que sur le
chantier le coup pré tombe en juillet on
a pris que notre maître d'heure en fait
a fait une éducation judiciaire et donc
on se retrouve avec la maison dans cet
état là et le souci c'est que il y a une
utilisation judiciaire avec une grande
partie de notre budget maison qui est
parti avec
50000 euros déboursés en acompte sous la
pression du maître d'oeuvre pour l'achat
de la charpente et de la menuiserie
notamment après une demande de créance
pour récupérer leur argent rester
infructueuse et des relances à
l'assurance du maître d'oeuvre pour
l'instant sans réponse le couple se
retrouve pris à la gorge financièrement
actuellement on est en location donc
avec un loyer d'à peu près 1000 euros
nous devons payer ensuite le crédit
immobilier 1200 euros par mois donc on
ne peut pas se permettre de payer un
loyer et un crédit immobilier à la fois
alors que les défaillances d'entreprises
du bâtiment explosent il faut donc
redoubler de vigilance insiste cet
avocat avant de signer les devis d'abord
vérifier la santé de la société auprès
de sites spécialisés comme société.com
son ancienneté plusieurs années sont à
priori un gage de sérieux prudent
ensuite sur les acomptes le rythme de
leur versement est strictement régi par
la loi
enfin privilégiez un contrat de
construction de maison individuelle plus
protecteur dans le cadre de ce contrat
vous serez protégé en tant que
particulier vous aurez ce que l'on
appelle une garantie de remboursement de
vos acomptes cela signifie que si le
constructeur est liquidé vous aurez une
assurance qui vous remboursera
on va vous présenter notre maison un tas
de parpaing
Mathieu et Marion eux ont décidé de
médiatiser leur mésaventures sur
Instagram et lancer une cagnotte en
ligne afin de relancer les travaux au
plus vite avec un autre maître d'œuvre